the jurgen experience we're here to talk
about what the [ __ ] is happening
to the restaurant industry during this
pandemic and how crazy it is
um you know i i i've talked about this
before
but having you guys on so you could say
firsthand what it's been like to you and
what this experience has been like
and how poorly it's been handled
just i want to give people a sense of
this at home what it's like from
two men who have made their living in
the hospitality and restaurant industry
yeah yeah i mean you want to start craig
well no
the funny thing is it's like we're the
rule followers
yeah we're the ones that are used to
handling the health department we're the
ones that are used to
you know doing everything that you know
from a safety standpoint
right and now we're the ones that are
being crushed
or being picked on so to speak by
that's the way a lot of people in the
industry feel because we're the ones
that are being shut down
in a city where a lot of other
businesses
are remaining open like malls
distribution centers
markets stores i mean you can go to a
mall and go
shopping you can go on an airplane from
la to
you know new york take your mask off and
eat
and that's okay but you can't eat
outdoors in a restaurant in la
that's following social distancing all
the health guidelines
i mean we know our business and so
it's been really hard since but it
started march 15th
we we shut down um we were then told to
put glass in between our
our boots so we did that we opened for
about 10 days
um we did uv lights in the in the in the
air conditioning
air filtration all the stupid absolutely
and then we built patios
um i've personally spent 250 000
abiding by the rules that were set forth
by the state by the county by the
governors by everybody and
and then to just kind of be shut down is
really really difficult and it's not
about me
and it's not about my restaurant and
it's not about john it's not about
it's about the employees it's about the
dishwashers and the busboys and the
servers
that live day to day on
the money that they make at the
restaurant it's their livelihood it's
how they feed their families
they send money back to the countries
that they came from
you know this is a larger issue
and and the reason it's a larger issue
is one little restaurant like craig's
we have 90 employees a furniture store
might have five or six
so when you shut down an industry like
that it really has a huge
economic impact and then it has a social
impact
because we all love to eat it's the one
thing we have in common
we like to get together as people i'm a
giant fan of restaurants i mean it's one
of my favorite things to do is to go out
to eat and
living in la it was so frustrating it
was
it was bizarre it did it doesn't make
sense now when you guys get the orders
when they tell you what's shut down or
what's open
is there anyone you communicate with is
there anyone that's involved in
government
that you've had conversations with no
that's the issue that's the biggest
issue that we have is they they refuse
to communicate to any of us
and i can't quite figure out why we hear
about it
on the news we've we've joined with
about 40
30 40 other like maine owners you know
that that are
all in the area and i think it's the one
thing that's kind of
a silver lining in all this is that
we've all teamed up to kind of like
try to figure out what's going on but we
find out about it from the news and we
have to just
make these moves within 24 hours it's
it's absolutely absurd and
we've reached out i've reached out to
newsome i reached out to garcetti and
they do nothing you know
they put you on phony task force they
lie
you know they they they have no idea how
serious this is and i commend you for
having us on no one else wants to speak
about it everyone's too scared of
backlash
but what backlash what i don't think
they understand it
i think it's crumbling right yeah i
think people are thinking it's black and
white
if you say anything somewhat negative
they view you as your anti
covid you're you're you're wanting to
kill everybody
right yeah but that's not the issue so
we're not denying that there's an issue
we're not denying that people are
getting sick
we're not denying that there are we all
are in this together so
how do you do it well how do you do it
smartly where should we be spending
money
um a perfect example is they're doing
rapid testing in certain areas
so instead of losing all of this revenue
why don't they invest in smart
technology
that has rapid testing that allows
people to go to a restaurant
get a rapid test you're positive you're
negative and then you get to go into the
restaurant like we did here today
exactly exactly we got rapid testing
today everyone's a fine where we could
sit down
have a conversation have no paranoia
yeah you could do that at a restaurant
you could have the
i was telling you about stubs barbecue
here in in austin where dave chappelle
and i have been doing great
establishment
we do 400 seats we test everyone people
get their way in advance
they test them yeah they get a kova test
which gives them a nice peace of mind
like oh great i don't have it
then you get to sit down and enjoy a
show and the place is packed
and so the business is making money
everyone's having a good time
it's it's possible well that's what
that's what a lot of people are doing in
la right so they're having parties in la
and a lot of them are doing rapid
testing beforehand so everybody gets a
wristband then everybody in the party
knows
that everybody's negative but isn't the
mayor's threatening to shut those kind
of parties down he's trying to shut
water off like yeah like and by the way
he's done it yeah water and power which
we're living in like a dictatorship i
really i literally feel like la's like a
third world country right now
never seen anything like this well if
you go to venice or you go to downtown
l.a and you see the encampments it's
[ __ ] bananas yeah i mean third world
countries wouldn't allow that [ __ ]
but it's worse this is some sort of
dictatorship happening
that uh we to me is a bigger picture
if if if other uh
governments if other states county
cities see that they can just shut an
industry down so easily
get a name for themselves get their name
out there
what's stopping everyone else from doing
this exactly it's new powers
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience